what can I say I got the girl
cheers iris to your big day feels so
good just to be away from it all I can't
believe you're really doing this
I can have my happy ending so can you
I'm supposed to be y'all know my mentor
Barry
[Music]
showing me how to love again
showing me
that love is the most important thing we
have
we got incoming Nazis
this where did I get her
I did not cease from 1945 when a crash
wedding crab legs delicious visitors
from another earth over there more than
one there are 52 actually there's a 53rd
earth and it's called earth acts they
want someone to bow to worship to mean
we're tourists not greeting ruling
[Music]
if you're gonna show these people that
this earth belongs to us will not
surrender we will not back down we will
keep fighting so get the hell off our
earth where you still can
thanks for your help
we're not done helping yet our enemies
are still on your earth Olli don't call
me that
give it time I'll get through that
crusty exterior no you really won't I
was talking to you crisis on earth a
crossover event starts Monday November
27 hey everybody's surprise surprise
they dropped the full trailer for the
crossover early I wasn't expecting this
to like later in the evening but it's
happening next week if you didn't know
about that
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's also a new round of that flash
ring giveaway I'll announce a new winner
at the end of this so you can kind of
see how they cut this is sort of a
narrative progression across the four
episodes so you pick up with Barry and
iris getting ready for the wedding like
it's basically the week of their wedding
and it's like oh my god I can't believe
this is happening
Supergirl and Felicity have come over
they're pre-gaming with iris and killer
frost Barry and Oliver looking like
they're trying on their tuxes this looks
like it's all happening you know way
before the actual wedding happens they
joke about having the happy ending you
see that Wally is back I know there's
been a whole bunch of questions about
him he's going to be on this week's
episode of the flash so they'll explain
what he's been doing and the really cool
thing about his character is is that I
did find out that he's going somewhere
specific
like he's physically going to be going
somewhere you notice heat wave in the
background just chugging another beer I
love the look on Barry's face when he's
walking through the reception and
everybody's drinking he sees Alex and
Sarah sharing shots together and he just
gives him that look like he knows
they're getting ready to do something
crazy but I think the idea is is that
the crossover because we're gonna be
seeing the evil versions of characters
you'll see some alternate pairings so
I'll talk about that when we get to over
girl stuff but all this actual wedding
ceremony footage is still from the
Supergirl episode you can see pretty
much all the characters from all the Big
Show's are in attendance I know
everyone's wondering about Martian
Manhunter because he doesn't appear very
prominently in any of these trailers but
the thing about the Rays character the
actor that's playing him he's actually
sitting next to captain Singh here but
just remember that because we've never
met him they kinda have to do the
explainer for who he is what his powers
are how he got his powers then of course
we get the Nazis they totally go for the
Indiana Jones line that was like the
first joke that I made after they
announced that Nazis would be the
of the crossover I hate these guys
I think heatwave even said that in a
previous season of legends of tomorrow
but in short order you see everybody
throw down so you see a couple people
actually brought weapons with them
Oliver has a retractable bow I'll be
interested to see if they did some CG
for that or if it's all practical
effects this is confirmed as earth X
Prometheus like you can see the SS band
on his arm there and it looks very
different from the evil version of
Oliver so a lot of people are wondering
who's underneath the mask it's not going
to be Josh Segarra so it won't be the
actor who played him on arrow season 5
but they've been so secretive about it
so Colton and Tommy are still pretty
high up on my list but it just could be
anybody so be prepared for big twists
when the mask comes off but the
interesting thing here is that obviously
there's a big over girl versus Supergirl
fight it looks like based on the way
they cut this footage she takes her down
relatively quickly because evil Oliver
comes in with his mask on and hugs her
over his arm and takes off but then in
the other part of the trailer you
actually see them fighting up in the sky
so I'm wondering when these scenes are
happening so I'm guessing when they come
back to STAR Labs here this is when we
pick up during the arrow part of the
crossover because remember that's the
second part they switch the order of the
show's flash is the third episode of the
crossover the other biggest thing that
made me turn my head is that they said
that there are 52 plus one earths and I
actually expected it to be infinite so
they're going with new 52 rules I think
just in the name of simplicity so if you
ever wondered the total number is 53 now
the reason why they call it Earth X is
because it's such a crap planet like
it's literally given no designation
which is why the X in Earth X just
stands for X it's not intended to be a
Roman numeral so it's not like Crysis on
earth 10 it's literally just earth X
another really crazy moment here is that
you actually get some Nazi paraphernalia
and it looks like evil Oliver is
actually the Fuhrer in this time period
so I know you know Hitler would have
been alive during World War two but I
think the idea is is that by this point
he was either killed or he
and red Sun style from the comics
they've all adopted this philosophy
because they've been raised within this
ideology so you know getting into
alternate pairings of characters over
girl is with him like they're a thing on
earth X so it's kind of like crisis on
two earths where you have a low man
who's in a relationship with super woman
which is like their evil version of
Wonder Woman so it makes sense because
they're borrowing some of the plot
points from that like the fact that they
have a doomsday device in the doomsday
device from crisis on two earths you get
a shot of evil Cara explaining her
ideology to Supergirl so you have sort
of the battle of morality this seems
like it's relatively early in the
crossover because they haven't met the
freedom fighter character so I'm
guessing that they rescue them from this
firing line and then they learn about
the resistance of Earth X with citizen
cold the Ray the other characters shot
of citizen cold and Oliver looking very
much like comic book citizen cold zari
in Amaya with their totems when they're
all lined up you actually sees re
wearing a version of her comic book
costume this seems like it's from much
later in the crossover Cisco and
Harrison wells on the Waverider this is
probably from later in the crossover we
finally get a shot of Black Canary and
wild dog versus the evil version of
Oliver for some reason there's a bunch
of crazy ninjas who knows where they
come from maybe that has something to do
with prometheus this is Supergirl after
the fight with over girl like after they
both kind of take each other out this is
evil Oliver on the Waverider before the
big final battle killer frost looking
like she's you know like the new version
of killer frost where she's a little
more balanced love this shot of earth
one Oliver just getting his ass handed
to him just lying there like holy
uber girl versus Sara she's died a
couple times I'm sure she's not afraid
to die again lo that citizen cold calls
Oliver Ollie just more of a comic book
II thing like he's a very comic boogie
version of Captain Cold so it's only
natural that they would make a lot of
comic book II Green Arrow jokes but
everybody let me know what you think of
the footage obviously there's gonna be
some more footage that will drop later
this week so we'll just do video for
that when it drops but obviously flash
episode tomorrow so I'll be doing that
just like I normally would but just look
out for everything if you have any
specific questions or bonus videos that
you want for this just let me know in
the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
what
dereck Jordan please private message me
so I can get your contact details I'll
announce a new winner when I post new DC
so I have my Justice League deleted
scenes video that will probably be the
next DC video but you can click here for
a brand new Star Wars last Jedi trailer
and you can click here for all my
Justice League Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you